I love this woman my wife understands
I hope Franco understand but I love this
woman I should probably go and sit down
having said that because I don't know
how I don't know that I have better more
eloquent words than that they what
Vanessa Redgrave means to me what a
privilege and an honor what a joy and
what a love fest what sheer fun it is to
get to perform this remarkable play
Driving Miss Daisy with this endlessly
innovative and enchanting partner I am
awed by the risk she takes as an actor
other fearlessness I stand in profound
admiration of her courage both on and
off the stage I'm even impressed forgive
me for Nessa by her fierce stubbornness
in making a point after seven months of
performance I can honestly say that it
is my great pleasure to have my life
defined by 90 minutes eight times a week
on stage with Vanessa and Boyd I can
hardly wait to get to the theater to do
it again to share in that rich process
of discovery it is every actors
aspiration Vanessa's matchless
craftsmanship is a source of endless
revelation making each show as engaging
as full as fresh as ever I could have
dreamed so words are inadequate I have
barely scratched the surface of the
immense complexity of Anessa redgraves
you
gives F given perhaps a mere thumbnail
sketch of a powerful impact on the
worlds of stage and film and of course
on my life so I can end where I began I
love this woman
you